A lot of people don't know what's the means,
but this is a good one page at legs for days,
I guess change it probably cause that's
how is it to be the first person scooting in a corner booth at a restaurant?
Yeah. Yeah, because you gotta be like,
use your palms and scoot. Yeah. It's pretty boot boot.
It's pretty. It's pretty boot. It's pretty. Um,
especially if you're like a white guy that is wearing shorts,
you're a major. If you do that, white guys have the most, some,
um, what do you call it? Uh, um,
well, what's the, what's the word? It's a very easy word
where you can, what's the word where you can. Wow.
I can't even think of how to describe this word, but it's a very easy word.
Hold on. I got a second babies. If it come through, uh,
Oh geez. Jesus Christ. What a brain. Hold on.
This is not happening in a long time. Uh, potential. Wow.
Jesus. Yeah.
The most high some potential white guys are shorts and blonde hair for sure. Um,
okay, let's go to another one. Crystal. Leah, would you rather, okay.
Meghilla Megalodon at Megan underscore Sullivan.
Would you rather ride in this car or fly United? She knows.
I hate United because United sucks. They're run by cats. This is a,
Oh my we'll put the picture up. I mean, dude,
this truck, first of all, it's neon green with,
what are those snake eyes on the back that are the blinkers?
No, it's not Spiderman, but they do have ghost rider on the back window.
And just these decals on it. Love is lame on the top. K.
So deeper a holler for a dollar choke
hard. Just like, okay, well not necessarily. Oh my God, dude.
There's the hello? Kitty thing. And instead of the eyes,
it has boobs and it says, Hey guy,
you're a man. Cause you have your license. What are you doing?
I like girls that drink beer. S racists are a rapist.
My other ride is my sexy girlfriend. S a sexist.
I like to spoon, but I love to fork. I mean, dude, you don't,
you might as well put, right? Because you already put, Oh my God,
dude. The other vagina.
Oh my God, dude. It says real women's swallow, bro.
Imagine driving around in this. I love that edge
boobies. We stare because we care
ill for skin holds germs just for why to get medical.
Oh my God, dude.
I hate smelly. VADs just on the back of his car.
Oh, and the license plate is iMeet wagon
meet w.
UGM, Pennsylvania,
real men don't buy girls. I see the short bus is missing a passenger.
I mean this whole thing is the most offensive back of a car ever.
Uranus is huge. K not so not funny,
just so not funny to do the planet thing with the making it like it's an.
And then on the upper left of the back truck
back of the truck,
it says protected by acid spitting kittens for no reason.
No, it's not. And just ghost rider on the back, you know,
just like so offensive and then just go Strider.
Hello. You know? Oh my God.
I like to snap. I've never heard how bad the,
I like to snatch kisses and vice versa.
One thing you know about this guy is that he's white.
I mean any Asian or black or any
Asian guys would look at this car and be like this
and black guys would look at the car like this. They would have the, like the,
like that meme of the they'd be like, they'd have that look.
And Persian guys would watch this car and be like this.
Oh, Oh, what?
You don't know? I mean the.
The only person that would be like, Oh,
that's pretty funny. It would be like a white guy, you know?
Oh. Oh, Hey,
Hey. And they would call purchase would be like, Hey, check this fool out.
Look at this. What the bro? And Nima watt
or a mirror look what the.
Bro? It says, I like, I like girls that drink beer dog. You can't.
Oh. Hey,
imagine you're driving behind this guy and you see,
watch out the idiot behind me decal on there. You're busting him up or what
dude, ghost rider. That kills me. That ghost riders on it.
What not nice fart can
Oh, like a butt. Nice fart. Can it says, wow. This guy is for sure.
White and definitely has a beard.
There's no way this guy's like a clean cart guy.
Well, I love thinking about a Persian guy looking at this car.
Oh, Hey. How much would you, Hey, how much,
how much would you have to pay.
You drive around in that, that sort of purging? I would say. Um, all right.
Next one, I guess. Would you ride in this car or fly United? I mean, Hey,
fly United, but never be in that car, dude.
Oh, here's a good one. Roberto. Rob Herrera Jr. LOL. Why do you always say,
well, he meant as they say, but he didn't left out a word cause right into fast.
Got real excited. Why do you always say my opener instead of their actual name?
Because, because that's what they deserve, dude.
He's got the best job in comedy, man.
He goes out there does some makes thousands of dollars selling his merch
and he, I also don't always say it, but cause it's funny,
it's a joke because sway deserves.
Um, and then after that he did a follow-up tweet that says, say Christ.
Um, yeah. So that's it. Uh, that's what I do. That's why I do that.
And that's what I do. And that's it. That's it for the episode.